Welcome to the show. My name is Tamas
Morat. I work for Den Institute and my
guest today is Raymond Ibrahim, a Middle
East expert, scholar, author, uh,
history and visiting fellow at here in
Denb Institute. Thank you very much
Raymond for being
>> and the title of the the conversation is
what does Islam want from us? And
actually this is my first question in
general. What
>> what does Islam want from us being
non-Muslims, Western people?
>> Yeah.
>> Well, uh this is a ultimately a
doctrinal question because every
religion has world views. Some religions
have nothing to do with the secular or
things like expansion or politics and
some do. Islam happens to be very much
rooted in a political worldview. It's
not so much as a a spiritual exercise as
it is what you do in the now. So, of
course, Muslims have to do things like
pray and fast and Hajj and this all this
sort of thing. But things like jihad,
which of course has a very peorative
negative connotation today from a
non-Muslim point of view because it just
means war. But, uh, from a Muslim point
of view, it's seen as a good thing
because jihad is you're struggling to
expand the the the beautiful rule of
Islam into non-Muslim regions which are
considered living in it's called jaha
which means ignorance. So uh so my point
is Muslims see jihad as a good thing.
This is we're helping you because you're
an infidel and we want to bring the
goodness of Islam to you and that has
been always a part of the religion
doctrinally and historically. So I would
say um based on the historical precedent
Islam of course conquered and expanded.
Virtually the entire Islamic world today
is on non-Muslim regions.
Egypt all the way to Morocco, Syria, the
Middle East, Asia Minor, Turkey. All of
these were actually older Christian
regions than Europe, but they were
conquered. Spain was conquered, Balkans
all the way up to Vienna. So that's what
Islam has wanted. And uh now, of course,
it's it's being facilitated by the West
itself via migration and things of that
sort. But ultimately, Islam wants and
there's a saying in Arabic, which is u
Islam is not here to coexist or to be a
second. It's here to take over and rule.
And again, you can't understand this
without realizing from a Muslim point of
view, this is altruistic. This is good.
This is not this is not an evil thing.
So that's what I'd say they'd want.
>> And there is one theory that uh I'm just
wondering whether it's true or not that
the the Islam itself is a religion of
peace and only the radical Islam poses a
threat to the West. Is it true or not?
>> It's not true. This is a a westernmade
construct that does not in any way,
shape or form apply to authentic Islam.
Islam is Islam and uh there is no
moderate or radical. This is a false
dichotomy that we've created to
rationalize and make sense of Islam by
because no one wants to accept that
Islam is inherently fundamentally
radical. So what we do is we claim that
the Muslims who do not practice Islam,
who are who are basically secularized
cultural Muslims and who are possibly
assimilated, but they're not really
being Muslim. We say they're moderate
Muslims. They're actually just secular
Muslims, cultural Muslims, nominal
Muslims. Then we say the Muslims who
truly practice Islam, we call them
radical. Okay? But the religion itself
is radical because like I said, for
example, punishing up to killing the
apostate, the the Muslim, if you're born
into Islam, you're a Muslim. The Muslim
who tries to leave Islam becomes a
Christian, for example. Yeah, that's
part of the religion. Muhammad himself
says it. It's part of the law. That's
just one example. Polygamy. Okay.
Concubinage, sexual enslavement of
infidel woman during warfare. All of
this is completely uh part of the
religion. So when a Muslim does that,
how is that radical? It's just the
religion is radical. But again, this is
a false construct that Westerners have
made to make Islam more palatable to
them.
>> So it's interesting you claim that if a
Muslim believer takes the Quran and the
Hadith very seriously as a as a word of
God, it commands you to act in this way
and you must you have to do this way.
You cannot be a moderate man as a
religious man. Not not by by not by what
western western people mean by moderate.
Moderate uh moderate essentially means
from a western point of view that you
can sort of get you can assimilate and
live with sincerely western secular
laws. Well, Islam is its own law. Uh we
hear about Sharia or Sharia law all the
time. Well, Sharia is basically Islam.
Islam is just the name of the religion.
Sharia is how you live it. And uh so
Islam basically has its own laws for
Muslims. And many of these do contradict
what we would call western law, secular
law. Okay? If you're a Christian, if
you're a Jew, and you live under an
Islamic rule, you don't have equal
citizenship rights. Of course, that
contradicts the western paradigm. Uh
that's another example. Women don't have
equal rights. It's open. Uh in courts, a
woman's testimony is not equal to a man.
Okay? So, these sorts of things, again,
that's not radical. That's just Islam.
Um but this is why uh like but people
are just they want to insist that
there's a difference and only a few
minority are doing this sort of thing.
Um and I don't know what the number is.
Maybe they're not the majority. But the
point is when Muslims follow what we
call radical, they're not being radical.
They're just being pious.
>> I see. Uh masses of Muslims uh living in
in Europe now by migration and the
demography. They are overgrowth. their
population overgrows the the European
white population, original population
and uh many of them try to integrate
into the society which accepted them.
But um in your claim it means like uh
they truly the true Muslims they don't
even want to integrate into societies
because they don't want they don't want
by their religion respect the western
values and traditions. Is is that claim
true?
>> Yeah, that's the claim but it's very
nuanced and one has to understand. So
I'm not saying that this is a DNA thing.
I'm not saying if you're born Muslim
that you want to this. There are people
who are named Muhammad and they do live
a secular life and they can potentially
assimilate. But then there are others
who are named Muhammad and they follow
the prophet Muhammad and they don't
assimilate. Uh so in the end this is why
it gets tricky. Um you know it it's in
the religion. The question is is this
person following their religion or not?
And we can say this about Christians and
Jews and other people of every religion.
You have amongst the Jews the
ultraorththodox and then you have the
reformed secular, right? Um obviously
the reformed secular can be assimilated
wherever whereas the ultraorththodox
might not. Same thing with uh other
religions. Um so this isn't something
peculiar to Islam. You always have the
group that follows it and the group
that's you know prioritizes living and
getting by in their society. And it's
the same with Islam. But for those who
do follow it, yes, it's very tribal.
Islam actually commands Muslims in the
Quran to have hatred for non-Muslims.
This is Quran 60:4. Okay. So, and
because it's tribal, it was founded by a
tribal man, Muhammad, in the 7th
century. And so, basically, he took
tribalism and uh rearticulated through a
theological paradigm. So, now the other
is no longer just the other. He's the
infidel. And the the tribe isn't a blood
tribe. It's all the Muslims. So, it's
they even have this in the doctrines.
You have a the entire it's called DI
Islam which is the abode the world of
Islam and Dal Harb which is the world
world of non-Islam and the two must
always fight until the home of Islam
conquers the other one
>> but most of the Muslims in Europe are
assimilated Muslims they are not so
serious by religion as you mentioned
that but even if this tendency u in 20
30 year time uh do you share the concern
of many uh experts and average man that
the overgrowing population of Muslims
and the demographical change the
Europe's political cultural religious
landscape will be changed radically in
2030 years time are you afraid of this
>> well it's already happened we're
>> there will be a radical change
>> it's already happened but it's going to
be much worse of course uh the the more
the the more any country becomes Islamic
by population the more it becomes
Islamic by by culture and uh by society
we see this already in places I traveled
recently in um you know in England which
has large Muslim populations and I was
surprised to see everywhere I looked
they had um you know foot foot washing
uh for Muslims for prayer. So you that's
a society that is being Islamified
>> and you are not talking about no go
zones on Muslim
talking about average squares right
>> regular airport okay so that that means
they are acquiescing to Islamic uh
basically culture and society because
the numbers are growing and there's
another thing I should add to clarify
about my earlier point about who's
radical and who's not even within Islam
itself there's a doctrine and a teaching
which says when you are outnumbered and
weak you can be what we call secular you
can be moderate you don't have to
enforce jihad because it's not it's not
the right time. And then so there's a
lot of um doctrines and teachings and
historically this has also happened
where Muslims would behave as friends
amongst non-Muslims because they were
the minority and then when that number
grows it starts changing and the truth
starts coming out and I think we're
already seeing this in a lot of
countries. So um again this doesn't mean
there are truly moderates who are just
nominal. So it's just I'm just showing
you how complex this the the scenario
is. There's the radicals who are open.
There's the ones who are not religious
and who we call moderate. And then in
the middle you have those who are
shifting alliances depending on you know
where where where things go. And if if
the if the radicals start getting
stronger they join them.
>> And and what is the worst scenario in
this expecting for for the for the case
of UK or France in 20 years time? Well,
if if it comes to a point where uh you
know a country has now the UK they claim
I don't know 10 12% which doesn't sound
a lot but of course they're very
concentrated so it looks a lot but I
think the number is bigger but I think
of it if it reaches something like 25%
that's the end of it. It's going to be
essentially a a nation that prioritizes
Islam before anything else. And as that
number grows and as Muslims become
stronger, the tolerance for the the
natives is going to become even more um
severe or less tolerance basically. So
that's why these countries are either
places like England are either headed
toward are either going to be conquered.
Okay. Peacefully.
>> You you use the word conquer, right?
>> Of course.
>> Actually actually just came to my mind
that these walls are Turkish wars. It it
this this is we are sitting in a bastion
called the golden bastion. It was in
Turkish times when the Hungary was
occupied by occupied conquered by the
Turkish forces for 150 years and we we
know that we know the history
Hungarians. I'm a Hungarian man
>> and still I'm sitting nearby the Turkish
war but we kind of not immune to the
naivity that they can come back right
it's very strange.
>> Well and and this is the this is why
history is very important. This is why
that old adage, those who forget history
are doomed to repeat it, is actually
manifesting itself in Western European
nations. Uh even the same thing with
France. This is the home of the Franks,
the ones who are actually the heart of
the Crusades against Islam. And now it's
well, it's even worse apparently than
England or the UK or Britain as far as
the Muslims overrunning places like
Paris and and things like that. So, uh
it's so my you know, Islam never
changed. It still has the same
mentality. But what has changed is the
west which once used to fight back like
Hungary did. And this is why Hungary
still remembers. It was very recent. You
know the the occupation by the Ottomans.
And now the West has forgotten about its
heritage. It sees its own heroes who
defended it as the bad guys. It sees
Muslims as misunderstood victims. And
now it's trying to and all these are
lies on top of lies. Uh manufactured
lies by design meant to manipulate
exactly what we're seeing. And yeah,
it's it's it's basically a slow motion
suicide and they don't know what they're
doing.
>> I see we were talking about the European
situation, but one one question about
the Middle East because you are a Middle
East expert and we saw many uh trials of
uh jihadist Islamist movements to
conquer swath of territories like like
Al-Qaeda, by ISIS, by al-Nusra and we
can continue the names of the
organizations but they didn't succeed.
So the Arabic governments and with the
help military help with the US and the
western powers always tried to they were
successful to push back these forces.
But is the caliphate as an idea is
impossible project or in 20 years time
it can be a reality unfortunately. Yeah,
it was a historical real reality and we
had different manifestations of
caliphates all throughout history like
every other human polity. Sometimes it
falls apart and there's all sort of
circumstances where they clash and and
it gets taken over etc. But it is an
idea that is pivotal to Islam the
caliphate. It just comes from the word
khalifa. It comes from successor. So
after Muhammad you had a successor who
was the new political leader. The first
one was Abu Bakr. And so a caliphate is
is based on governance by a man who is
basically a religious leader following
in the footsteps of Muhammad. That is
the normal for um sort of paradigm for
Islam. That's what is expected. So of
course Muslims would love to have that.
And but like I this is what I mean. You
still have the political clashes. Okay,
which means which who's going to be the
leader? Is it going to be the Turks? Is
it going to be the Arabs? Is it going to
be the Persians who are Shia? Which is
another, you know, so obviously won't be
them. So you do have those clashes which
have happened historically which I guess
that's the good news. It won't make it a
very easy thing but it is the ideal that
I'm sure they all want to realize.
>> Is it possible?
>> Anything's possible that
>> Yeah, it's poss it's possible. They did
it before several times. I mean we've
had caliphates for the for the history
of Islam. We've had a lot more
caliphates than we didn't. The last one
was abolished at right around 1924.
So that's not like a century ago.
>> I see. Thank you very much. We are
talking about history and uh some
questions about the spiritual background
of the um Islam because um uh please
correct me if I'm wrong. I know uh the
Quran teaches or the Muslim teachings uh
teach the the the believers that the
previous books the Old Testament, the
Torah, the New Testament, the teachings
of Jesus were kind of originated from
the real God. But the final revelation
of God was through the book of Quran
which was uh re revealed to through a
angel to Muhammad. Is it right? So they
they consider the former books uh godly
books.
>> Yeah. What?
>> Because my question is the following.
Yeah.
>> Sure. Okay. So in a nutshell they
believe that uh there were scriptures
and and books were given to the people
of the book primarily this means Jews
and Christians. So yes the old and new
testament they believe was in origin
divine. However, the Bible that exists
today, which is used by Jews, the Torah,
and the Christians, according to the
Muslims, is wrong. It's been
intentionally distorted. So, for the
writers,
>> by the writers. So, for example, when we
grab the New Testament and it talks
about Jesus being crucified and
resurrecting and calling him the son of
God. Muslims believe that was added in
later. It's false. Okay? So, so, so
Jesus was a the true prophet, but Paul,
Apostle Paul was a false prophet because
he distorted original message of Jesus,
>> right? Uh, it could be that or someone
changed what Paul said in in the Bible.
But the bottom line is the Bible that we
have today according to Muslims is
false. Okay? It was originally true, but
the core teachings that we have are been
added later. So the Quran, which wasn't
a book revealed, it was a recitation
from the angel Gabriel to Muhammad, was
it was it it was it was supposedly the
new correction, bringing it back to the
way it was. Okay. So what so so now when
you look at the Quran and you read it
and it talks about everyone from Abraham
and Moses, Adam, uh all the way to
Jesus, it talks about them and there's
some similarities with the Bibles, but
then with the Bible, but then there's a
lot of differences. So the difference is
according to the Muslims is yes this is
the correction because what you said is
the wrong thing and and so Muhammad came
to bring it back to the truth.
>> Yeah my original question would be that
the how can uh the Muslim imams or
teachers resolve the contradictions
between the older books and the Quran.
that you answer the questions that this
is a
>> this isn't say methodical science
because they'll they'll look at the
older books and no matter how old it is
they'll say okay it was distorted 1500
years ago even it's still wrong you know
and the Quran you know makes it even
worse cuz the Quran is written much
later and there's a lot of problems with
how the Quran was written and there were
different versions and they ended one
you know one khalif burned most of them
and kept one so there's all sorts of
problems with the Quran itself
>> and talking about distortions there
there's a historical distion I'm telling
you uh personal story and 10 years ago I
was shooting a documentary in Jerusalem
and from the mostly from the pro aspect
from the as the Palestinians see that
and I had a Palestinian driver and we
were driving through the mount of Oliv
and looking down to the Temple Mount. We
saw the we saw the the Alexa complex
which is the
foundation is a Herodian temple the
Jewish temple and I told the driver that
look you are not believing the artifacts
but these stones are originated from
Jesus time from the Herald temple and he
told me that absolutely incorrect this
is Jewish myth and I told him connecting
to the previous question that you
believe that some parts of the New
Testament true Jesus is a true prophet
and Jesus was quarreling the Jewish
leaders in the temple. The New Testament
says so these are the stones by the
architecture I mean I mean the experts
these are the stones when Jesus was
there and Jesus was a true living person
he was a true prophet so he was there so
it's just a Jewish stones and he told me
this absolutely wrong question
he he didn't he didn't like the question
so what's your perception of it
>> it's it's just indoctrination because
they're taught when they grow up as as
children and the madresses that okay
anything the Christians and the Jews say
to you. It says this in the Quran. It
says that Christians and the Jews will
not be happy with you Muslims until you
believe what they believe. Okay? So
they're taught from a very young age
that any you know if their books or
their teachings in any way shape or even
if their archaeological findings
contradict what we teach that's because
they're liars naturally and they're
trying to they're still distorting the
truth because they want to corrupt us.
Do you believe that there will be a
generation maybe this generation we the
young people in in a Palestinian
territories in Arabic countries even in
Israel that they can overcome this kind
of denial miseducation a lot of people
yeah a lot there there's many people who
convert out of Islam some become
Christians some become atheists uh yeah
this is this is a real phenomena as well
so this is why it's a mixed bag it's
never so easy it's not all of them are
this or all of them are that you know
there's lots of things going on at the
same time there's westerners who are
converting to Islam because they're not
satisfied with secularism and
materialism and so in that way they're
gaining ranks that way too. So um but
yeah Islam itself for the Islamic Islam
is is built on a house of cards which is
why they have laws against what's called
blasphemy and apostasy. Blasphemy is
essentially anything you say against
Islam is blasphemy. going in front of
Muslims and declaring Jesus Christ as
the son of God is blasphemy because
Muhammad says the opposite and you're
saying he's a liar. So everything has to
be um uh contained and you can't
question it because once you really
start looking into the history of Islam
and the the way the Quran and the hadith
were put together, it starts falling
apart because there's a lot of question
marks, a lot of missing data, a lot of
uh um you know uh counter narratives to
what Muslims are taught. Ibra uh Raymond
you you just told me that some Muslims
find other religion and leaving the
Islam which is a dangerous thing by by
the Islam itself. I don't know whether
you met Hassan Yousef the the son of the
Hamas founder called Grim Prince. You
know him or
>> I think I'm I'm aware of him. I don't
think I met him. I I read his book and I
actually 15 years ago I had a chance to
interview him and he told me and it is
written in his book that the reason he
changed religion I mean uh became a
Christian was one sentence in the new
testament and I'm wondering what his
perception of this and he quoted one
sentence from Jesus love your enemy and
he told me that from from growing up as
a Muslim a radical Muslim family a
jihadist Islamist family uh hate your
enemy was a main teaching of the
foundation of the religion. And he told
me that uh love your enemy is so
irrational for a Muslim mind that he
needed to think about this for month
from months. And he became a Christian
because he thought that this is so
transcendent, so not instinctive, so not
a human instinct, so not uh manly
thinking that it's above all the
thoughts. Have you met this kind of
conversion stories before?
>> Oh yeah. Yeah. And it makes perfect
sense because the thing about Islam is
if you if you look at it, it's very
man-made. You know, the earliest
Christian theologians, uh, you know,
from all the way from, you know, St.
John of Damascus all the way to Aquinas
when they studied Islam, what they
understood is this man is an impostor
who created a religion that gives men
what they want. It gives them wealth,
plunder women. Okay? You can exercise
your anger. you can go kill, you can,
you know, subjugate, conquer, seize
women, seize property, and then you're a
good guy, and you go to heaven. So, it
was it was it was seen as a man-made
religion. So, it it makes perfect sense.
But, of course, man-made religions do
not necessarily bring the satisfaction
of the soul that Christianity would,
even though, as you were pointing out,
Christianity, its teachings are
counterintuitive to the human mind. And
that's what makes it divine. You know,
hate, love your enemy. Who can think of
that? that's so counter to how we
naturally are. Um, and so when you have
a religion that says that and you think
about it and you do it and uh it's it's
a satisfying, elevating, edifying
experience, then you start um I think
appreciating the truths of that religion
versus the other.
>> Raymond, we came to the final point and
my last question is about the future
because there are some prophecies in the
Quran, there are some prophecies in the
in the Bible and there are parallelism.
Um actually I'm taking the third
religion Judaism too because and it's
it's it's about the Messiah the person
of the Messiah because I see that I know
I'm familiar with the Jewish point of
view that the Messiah will come and as a
Christian I'm familiar with the Jew
Jesus position this is the second coming
of Jesus as a king but the Muslim
version of this the Mai problem is there
any parallelism with the three types of
messiah who um differences,
similarities. Can you explain this
complex situation?
>> Sure. Well, the similarities again and
people who try to connect and show you
how Muslims love Jesus as uh Tucker
Carlson famously said. Some of the
similarities are they believe that Jesus
will be uh he will come during judgment
day. He's a he's a major role. He's
going to fight the I think the de who's
like sort of a if you want an antichrist
figure. Um and I believe he'll kill him.
And uh so he so so that's one aspect
where you can see but the differences
are just that uh so other things that
Jesus will do when he comes is he will
break all the crosses kill all the pigs
and cancel what's called Jiza. Jiza is
in the Quran Quran 9:29 which says fight
the people of the book Jews and
Christians until they either convert or
pay Jiza pay tribute and live as
secondass citizens. So by canceling that
Jesus is basically saying now uh
Christians and Jews have to either
become Muslim or die. They can't pay
anymore. Okay. So this is again an
excellent example of how different you
know the the Jesus and all the prophets
in Islam are from the biblical version.
Um you know he's he's breaking the cross
because he wants to show all the silly
Christians he was never crucified and he
never died and he never was resurrected
because that's what Islam teaches. and
he's killing the pigs because you know
Islam is halal you know it's it's kosher
it doesn't eat pigs and um and doing
that so but also the um the mahiism the
mahi is the guided one he's the he also
comes in and you know brings some sort
of rule uh Islamic rule to the world
it's actually not unlike I would say
Christianity and Judaism not very it's
not a very clear vision it's just very
snippets and ideas from hadith this
isn't in the Quran um and it also
depends And if you look at the Sunni or
Shia version,
>> I see. So there is a clear contradiction
between the two the Juda Christian
tradition and the Islam perception. So
they are not waiting for the same guy.
>> No, no, no, no, no. They're not they're
not waiting no for Jesus. I mean the
Jewish Messiah, we don't know who that
is. And uh but they're not they're
waiting for Jesus in a different
capacity because he's a prophet, but
he's not coming to judge as the son of
God. Far from that. He's coming to
actually punish Christians. I see.
>> Raymond, thank you very much for the
deep analyzis. Thank you for being here.
>> Thank you. My pleasure.
>> And thank you for watching us. Byebye.
>> Bring back the flame.
Bring back the fire and the rightous
name.